[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website cover
anything else 99designs was created to
make great designs accessible to
everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance
testing prototype covers and getting
prototype covers for the 4-hour body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one-to-one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators it blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free and $99
upgrade on your first design again
that's 99 designs dot-com forward slash
Tim
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom I have used LegalZoom myself
for many of my businesses and many of
the icons on this podcast have actually
used LegalZoom for instance Matt
Mullenweg of WordPress Fame CEO of
automatic which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on LegalZoom LegalZoom is a
reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted to
help with their businesses whether
that's setting up a will doing a proper
trademark search forming an LLC setting
up a non-profit or finding simple cease
and desist letter templates man do I use
a lot of those LegalZoom is not a law
firm but they do have a network of
independent attorneys available in most
states they can give you advice on the
best way to get started provide contract
reviews and otherwise help you run your
business and important there are no
surprises LegalZoom provides complete
transparency that means upfront pricing
customer reviews and a satisfaction
guarantee check out legalzoom.com today
to see how they can make life better and
easier for you and your business if
you're pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted enter
promo code Tim T IM at legalzoom.com to
save 15% that's t IM for 15% off check
it out
legalzoom.com
Oh dodge aha this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show or it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types from business
entertainment sports anything you can
imagine really my guest today is Mark
Bell at mark smelly bell hon Twitter who
is the founder of super training gym
found in Sacramento which is oftentimes
referred to as the strongest gym in the
West prior to opening his own gym he
spent years studying training under the
legendary Louis Simmons and Westside
barbell mark is no stranger to the iron
at all his best geared lifts in
competition include a 1025 pound squat
that's a 465 kilos a 832 pound bench
press that's 377 kilos and a 738 pound
deadlift that's 335 kilos mark is also
the inventor of the patented slingshot a
device utilized to assist a lifter in
maintaining proper benchpress form while
also allowing the lifter to use more
weight or perform more reps he now has
an entire line of products and has been
spectacularly successful in this episode
we cover a lot including his most
important lessons for building strength
how to avoid injury and break down the
lesser-known or some lesser-known
training techniques that nearly everyone
overlooks how he became a millionaire by
offering his gym memberships for free
which in and of itself is just an
incredible story and much much more
so we really dig into the audio we
recorded this at his gym and while there
we took a full tour of his facility
looking at some crazy equipment and
custom mod of equipment that he has at
the super training gym in Sacramento if
you want to see that video you can and
it is that Tim blog /super training all
one word tim dot blog /super training
and for links to everything in this
episode as usual you can find the show
notes at tim blog forward slash podcast
so without further ado please enjoy mark
smelly bell
mark welcome to the show
thanks Tim I'm fired up to be here man
this is gonna be fun yeah it's been a
while since I have hung out among the
goliaths here at super training gym this
is my first time in the new location
like I like the digs I'm glad we got you
you know finally to the new spot here
we're having a lot of fun here and it's
uh you know this is a kind of a dream
come true this is ten years in the
making super training gyms been around
since 2006
and you know I started off in somebody
else's gym and then I had my own spot
for awhile where we were nearly among a
funeral home where they were sacrificing
all kinds of animals and [ __ ] like that
that was really bizarre but to come to
this and have be able to offer the gym
the gym is free super trainings free and
it's just a dream come true to be able
to share knowledge and my mission and
goal in life is to make the world a
better place to lift so explain the
business model so how did you decide how
does that work how does it work yeah no
no honestly like what's how did you make
that decision you know when I first did
it one of my good friends asked me he
said he said why why are you making the
gym free cuz if the gym wasn't always
free the gym used to be 125 bucks a
month I just kind of made that value up
out of the four times a week that we get
together and the amount of coaching and
I was offering everybody to me it would
have been valued at a lot more than that
but power lifters typically don't have
that kind of dough to shell out to 300
bucks a month so I made it 125 but when
I switched it to be free one of my good
friends he was like why are you making
the gym free and I said to become rich
and famous and from that moment on
that's when things started to really
kick in and things started to really
groove because thick because at that
point everything started to make a lot
more sense to me it was like neo and the
matrix everything just kind of started
to come together one by one thing
started to unfold my brother passed away
kind of around that time and it was just
a message to me it was very simple your
life is short I don't give two [ __ ]
about what other people think I need to
get myself heading in the right
direction and I need to do the things
that I want to do and I need to follow
through with my hopes and my dreams
than be so fearful of stuff a lot of
people are fearful of kind of jumping in
with two feet into stuff and I was like
you know I can't have that mentality
anymore it's just not gonna work it
didn't work for my brother and it's not
gonna work for me so I need to just
forge forward and try to figure out a
way to keep moving forward and to share
the message I want to share and to do it
my own way do the things my own way so
making the gym free was a byproduct of
the slingshot being invented and the
slingshot giving me the financial means
to make the gym free but I knew that the
gym being free was going to give me back
everything tenfold and aside from that
the or in addition to that rather the
slingshot was made inside the walls of
super training gym so I can never really
repay super training gym what it's done
to me no matter how we slice it so the
gym being free is uh just my way of
paying back to the Powerton community
did you make that decision in part
because it was just consuming like 10%
of your bandwidth having to keep track
of membership payments and all the
details that go along with that kind of
profit and loss and by freeing it up it
just made your focus on other things
more pure and what are the rules like
can anybody show up anytime they want or
what's the commitment that you look for
if anything I like some of the words you
just said there you mentioned the word
pure I'm not a like the humanitarian of
the [ __ ] decade or anything like that
it's it's nothing it's nothing corny or
weird like that because financial gain
is on the front of my mind it's not in
the back of my mind it's on the front of
my mind that's you know I'm a scoreboard
driven person you know I'm trying to put
points up on the scoreboard and as an
adult how do you put points up on the
scoreboard you put points up on the
scoreboard by by making money right
dollars and cents we're talking about
right and so that's that's kind of the
mission that's kind of the goal and so
by making the gym free it allowed it
gave me a testing ground for a lot of
the products that I have it really
opened the doors for a lot of other
financial gain that maybe when I first
made a gym free I didn't recognize but
once I made the gym free it was I kind
of just started to think more in terms
of okay like I literally own
everything that's in here including the
people now I basically purchased the
people in some weird way because they're
no longer paying me for my services I'm
allowing them to train here for free
with hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of dollars of equipment that gym is so
expensive to go over each piece of
equipment every barbell is specialized
every plate is specialized there's
nothing in there as normal especially
the people nothing in there it's normal
so everything's a little different in
there and because of that it allowed me
to kind of recognize that I have a place
of real strong testing ground where I
can test products and also I'm not a
product company only I'm 50% products
and 50% media without media social media
without YouTube and without the magazine
the magazine power magazine without all
these different formats I'm a subscriber
there you go as you know yeah and you
know without these different formats to
get the message out there than what I am
I you know so it's great to see that
it's all working through the podcast and
through other things trying to make the
products popular trying to make the gym
popular trying to make money all those
things are definitely on the front of my
mind you did mention how does a gym work
the way the gym works is is not that
complicated but what we do is we do have
an email address that's associated with
the gym it's not plastered everywhere
but if you do find it if you do work
towards finding it and you're able to
communicate back and forth with us then
you're able to come here so it's not
that complicated but we try not to
advertise too much the sign that you saw
out front today doesn't say gym we don't
make it super simple to get here and
then once you get here we sort of make
it a little bit confusing on what's the
next step you know somebody's like hey
I'm supposed to talk to Marcus I don't
know what's going on I'm like I don't
know what's going on either like I don't
know Marcus I'm just I'm just a fly on
the wall here I have no idea yeah
they're like they're like well don't you
own the place I'm like yes sort of don't
worry about it so we make it a little
confusing goal if some heavy stuff will
talk and a half-hour yeah and then you
know when I see people in here working
like if you're not sweating I'm not
talking to you there's just no point
we're not gonna have this it's about yes
yeah
intimidated by all you have fact that's
right there are some
back there for sure but if I'm not
seeing that you're working then there's
there's no room for me to have
conversation with you I'm not gonna help
you out of nowhere and just start giving
you a bunch of advice unless I see that
you're hungry for it yeah and you have I
observed because we're effectively in
your recording portion of the office at
super training gym and someone came in
earlier skew HQ to talk about the
schedule so the schedule for the gym can
you lay out the days of the week and
what you do on them so the gym schedule
is we get together every Tuesday and
Thursday during the week from about 3:00
until approximately 7:00 and then
Saturday Sunday is from 9:00 until about
1:00 in terms of like the training split
it's pretty simple we do lower body once
a week we do upper body once a week I'm
sorry we deadly deadlift and squat once
a week so I guess would be lower body
twice a week an upper body about once a
week every Tuesday is deadlifts every
Thursday is bench and every Saturday is
squats after a while it starts to get
kind of pre-programmed into your body
and your body is kind of like today's a
squat day today's rather than being
Tuesday it's dead lifting you know
that's how meat heavy we get around here
when you when you start just
instinctively exploding off of the
toilet into into like exploding on the
toilet and into the bin you know you've
had too much pre-workout stimulus number
one and it's squat day that's right so
first of all I want to recommend a
couple of things first is and there's a
poster here on the wall two
documentaries that I think offer a lot
of insight into your background and your
family and also your brother because I
don't know if we'll have time to really
dig into the details but bigger bigger
stronger faster which is how we
originally met I believe yeah because I
saw the documentary I was really
impressed it so the tagline is is it's
still cheating if everyone is doing it
this is about performance and drugs it's
a great dock which was made by your
brother
yeah and now it's kind of like it's kind
of in that classic status yeah oh yes
it's and and I liked it so much number
one I reached out to try to find you and
realized oh my god you're in Northern
California and then travel to Sacramento
to embarrass myself I was like who is a
skinny guy who is this guy kicks at me
and stuff what's going
here and then the other is prescription
thugs right which is covers a lot of
semi related topics but also goes very
deep with your family so those are just
two things on people to check out for
further watching and resources that I
would HIGHLY encourage checking out the
training split could you talk about Lois
Simmons and Westside and what are some
of the key lessons you learned yeah I
trained at Lois Simmons for about a year
also worked with him and coached under
him for about an additional year beyond
that and for people who don't know him
could you just give them an overview
yeah Lois Simmons is the owner of the
pretty much the strongest gym in the
history of lifting he created a
community that was so competitive and so
strong that thousand pound squats were
routine 800 pound benches were routine
and 800 pound deadlift are very routine
now keep in mind this is back a few
years when geared power the thing was a
little bit more acceptable now people
have taken the power to think you're off
the power of thing gear is very
supportive and it adds additional pounds
to what you can actually lift and for
those people who who don't follow pound
lifting gear in this particular case
referring to multi ply bench press
shirts and deadlift suits and so that
looks like a straightjacket type of feel
that improves your leverage
yeah proves your leverage but regardless
of what people wore and didn't wear at
the time that was the style lifting that
was popular and Louie created the
fastest most explosive strongest
athletes in the game without question
and he would have what seemed like 10 15
guys at a time that were just crushing
world records in some different weight
classes and year by year you know the
things would change a little bit in the
gym and they'd get new guys in and he
would still create you know monster
after monster didn't matter just the
only thing that would change in there
was the names the numbers would go up a
little bit the names when there would
change a little bit but it was still the
same thing still him you know Westside
barbell kicking the crap everybody Louie
was a pioneer in a way of bands and
chains being utilized in training the
bands and chains helped to accommodate
resistance the weights are lighter at
the bottom and they're heavier
the top as your body becomes in a more
advantageous position and more favorable
position you're getting more weight on
the bar as your body is in the least
favorable position such as the bottom of
a bench press or the bottom of a squat
you have less chain weight or less
resistance from the band and so it gives
you an opportunity for a lot of things
number one it help can help you produce
more force which is great in any sport
it can also help you to just be faster
be more dynamic the other thing that
it's gonna do is going to allow you can
help prevent injuries because as I
mentioned when you're at the bottom of
the lift there's less weight on you you
have less overall weight on you so for
example if you were to benchpress with
some bands on the bar at the bottom of
the lift if you had three plates on the
bar like I was using today it would be
you know let's just say it's 50 pounds
of bands total at the bottom with 315
and be about 365 pounds at the bottom
and if it jumped up to a hundred pounds
extra it'd be about four 15 at the top
so as you can see again the weights are
light at the bottom heavier at the top
it allows for acceleration you can
accelerate through the weights and
allows for a kind of consistent tension
on those weights so Louis paired up
speed training dynamic effort training
as he calls it with maximal effort
training so he basically attacked
training from two different ways and
there's a third way I'll talk about in a
second but its main two ways that he
attacked it from were from the
perspective of if I can move faster if I
could become more explosive I can move
more weight because in some cases it
just becomes a race against the clock if
you go to benchpress 300 pounds and it's
gonna take you 12 seconds the odds of
you making one rep last that long like
that is probably probably not very good
anybody out there that's listening in
the show that can benchpress
even 300 pounds take 200 pounds and try
to try to go 5 seconds on the way down
with a 5 second pause and 5 seconds on
the way up and you'll quickly realize
that time management of those lifts is
crucial you want to get underneath the
weight and get it the hell over with as
quickly as possible so the speed element
in the speed aspect is crucial the other
way that he recognized
you know a just gaining strength was to
simply just get stronger work on
handling more weights and trying to
figure out different ways and different
angles to handle more weights he came up
a lot of new and creative and different
ways of handling big weights so it
wouldn't kill your central nervous
system and so it wouldn't kill your
knees and kill your elbows and things of
that nature because he started used a
lot of specialized barbells and
specialized he would squat off of boxes
back in the day and then he started
squatting off of foam he's even he's
even put Springs inside a barbells to to
create a different effect that's one
barbell in particular had a spring in
the middle and it kind of looked like
the spring inside the rollover toilet
paper or something on a shake weight but
you would squeeze the barbell together
it was like on a regular bar like for
bench pressing you'd squeeze the bar
together and sure enough it blow that
blow your chest up it would crush you so
he had a lot of great innovative ways
but those were the two main ways he
thought of to increase strength one was
to max out to go as heavy as possible
max effort a max effort day and to
choose different exercises each week
that's kind of the basis of the
conjugated system you might do a box
squat one week you might do a regular
squat the next next week after that you
might squat with chains the variety is
both good and bad
sometimes a variety got to be so large
that you no longer knew what the hell
you were doing anymore and sometimes the
variety was a welcome change because you
might be the season lifter that is just
so tired of doing the same [ __ ] over and
over again you can't even the other the
other huge advantage of changing things
up is in a good way you kind of don't
know where you stand
which i think is kind of nice because
being a competitive lifter and being a
competitive athlete for so long you can
get really frustrated and you and the
ups and downs can be very very the Downs
for sure can be very well the ups too
they can all be very negative actually
because you don't want a hat you want to
be kind of even keel as an athlete you
don't want the highs and lows to ever be
too great so they can kind of throw you
for a loop when something unexpected
does happen and the third way to
increase strength is to have more muscle
mass so Louis recognized just
hypertrophied just some bodybuilding
style training the repetition effort
method as he would call it just simply
once you're done with some of the main
movements you would do three sets eight
four sets eight five sets of ten
basically get in more work more volume
with different exercises that would
allow you to help build muscle mass so
you'd get done with the main lift and
the overall volume of the main lift may
not be through the roof because there's
only so much you can do with a barbell
you'd move into assistance exercises
that's where you'd get your volume in
and that's where you'd build muscle and
if you look at a lot of these concepts
whether it's the bands at the chains box
squats board I don't know if they're not
short presses we have I guess what what
are they technically they're two by
fours I think so yeah just sort of put
together different heights so you can
stop the bar from in this case the chest
at say form just a car range of motion
functional range of motion have become
very popular do you have a particular
opinion about when people should
incorporate versus not incorporate these
things because you could go to I'm sure
many different gyms or if somebody who
is bench pressing 45 pounds and they
have like 17 different accessories for
someone who is athletic but not a power
lifter getting started focusing on these
three lifts at what point would you
introduce things like bands and chains
and so on it's a great great question
you know first of all I think that a
little bit of lifting a little bit of
training what we're doing when we're
going to the gym is what I call
artificial exercise we're making [ __ ] up
because we don't have to do the same
tasks that we had to do hundreds hundred
years ago
we're not carrying buckets of water and
we're not digging ditches and we're not
building stuff as much as we were in the
past and so you got to make [ __ ] up to
to get to be muscular to even look manly
you gotta like make stuff up to to kind
of make up some ground for the girly
[ __ ] that men do nowadays
that's kind of where we're at I mean
seriously hanging out on a computer all
day and all these different things were
not really things that we were probably
designed to do but anyway who long
longer story for another day right Kelly
Starrett in here and Epson behind he
okay exactly let him go off yeah yeah
yeah exactly exactly I think that uh one
of the key components to kind of all of
this is that when you're a newer lifter
that you just try to keep it simple and
even as you advance anything seems too
good to be true it is there's no tricks
unfortunately there are some things that
can help you use the term and I love the
term accelerated learning that is
probably the only trick that there
really is like find somebody who knows
what they're doing and rub elbows with
them and try to find other people that
know what they're doing because that
will actually accelerate you to the top
faster than you can imagine much faster
than finding like some secret fat burner
or something like that finding people
that know how to lose body fat finding
people that know how to build strength
and getting around those people is going
to be a crucial element for newer
lifters I always just suggest and even
even older listeners again five five
exercises is about all that you need you
don't need to be in the gym for hours on
end if you feel good for the day and you
want to do more exercises and then ride
it out and go ahead and feel better and
and do it but a real crucial thing to
your training and this is something that
has taken me a long time to learn your
training should make you feel better and
not make you feel worse if you can kind
of always keep that in mind your
training should make you feel better and
not make you feel worse think about that
the next time you have some stupid idea
to do something you're like oh I'm gonna
try to run 12 miles and you haven't ran
one mile in the last couple years yeah
Tim Ferriss knows exactly what I'm
talking about I do I still follow his
social meaning he's doing something
crazy all the time yeah we both have
spent we specialize in certain types of
of gross indulgence yeah so you just
want to be you want to be careful I mean
if you haven't sprinted in a long time
it's probably not a great idea to go do
ten sets of two hundreds you know I
don't attract some weary you got an
easier way into stuff you got to take
your time you got to build up towards
something and then once you build up
towards something you can start to add
and more stuff the bands and the chains
and stuff are great anyone can use them
I never I never want to tell and
new person that they can't do something
because why not let them enjoy
themselves the same way or like let them
have access to all the same stuff let
them use a slingshot let them use bands
let them use boards or whatever they
want to do but just kind of keep in mind
the basics are gonna be the stuff that
really gets you there people from the
70s didn't have any problem gaining
strength and they didn't need any
special tools back then it they had less
stuff than we do now well and a lot of
what Louie does is based on his reading
of the Soviet research yes as I
understand it which was from I mean
certainly those previous decades
yeah Olympic weightlifting yeah and just
as to underscore a couple things so the
the speed or other time being your enemy
I mean I've heard this from also Olympic
lifting right same story it's like the
less time you spent under the bar the
better and that was from a guy named
Jersey Greg rec who was a four-time
world champion in Olympic weightlifting
the footnote that I placed in my head
when you mentioned five exercises what
would if you were picking five exercises
for a novice or an intermediate right
like let's say somebody who
hypothetically was an athlete may be a
baseball player I'm just making this up
soccer player in college has a regular
sort of physical practice but has not
lifted per se has never had any
instruction
what would the five exercises be this
actually is very simple take the
activity that you want to do and think
about if you were to ask a hundred
people if you asked a hunter if you got
in front of a hundred people and said
hey what five exercises you think would
be good for a triathlete
give or take there's going to be a
couple things in the gym that that
somebody might say one thing over
another but in general there's gonna be
some sort of a press maybe two pressing
movements maybe you have maybe one
person's excited about incline bench and
maybe one person's excited about
overhead so you have two pressing
movements maybe somebody in the room is
a big fan of doing squats so you have a
squat maybe somebody else rather see
like a leg press maybe somebody else
trying to see like a deadlift go around
the room and you're gonna you know you
can kind of narrow it down maybe you end
up with ten exercises total you can
probably agree upon about five exercises
right now take those five exercises and
start to think about how do I build up
these exercises through other exercises
so for example assistant section yes for
example we we have you know things like
a an overhead press what are some of the
muscles involved in overhead press you
don't have to be insanely and
intelligent to be able to grasp some of
this you know what just kind of think
about what are some of the what are some
of the muscles that you see flexing in
the mirror when you do some of these
movements your triceps are fire and
right your shoulders are firing so can a
lateral raise help your overhead press I
would think so gonna help build up your
shoulders maybe help with stability
would work in the back of your shoulder
help make the entire shoulder more
stable so you can press more weight sure
well the triceps are involved heavily so
you start to break things down in that
sense and things start to become very
very simple and they become a lot less
complicated when you think about that's
one of the things I really loved about
the Westside barbell approach is that's
kind of where I started to really see
that kind of stuff and my eyes became
very open to the fact that you can kind
of narrow everything down by what is
gonna help me get to that what's gonna
help make me better in a particular
sport so if you're grappling maybe you
want you know maybe you want more hips
so maybe you're gonna squat a little bit
more maybe you're gonna do more sumo
deadlifts maybe you can do more med ball
throws maybe you're gonna do some more
athletic stuff maybe some twisting of
some kind you're gonna kind of think of
a few exercises that you want to do on a
regular basis and you want to try to
figure out a way to overload those
exercises and ways to become more
efficient those exercises and so from
that standpoint it gets to be very
simple you kind of think about just even
building the muscles rather than
thinking about I always hate the term
like functional because I I don't
understand what a non functional
movement would be um the human body you
know you see some people that are gifted
at like dancing or figure skating or
gymnastics or any I mean the human body
can do all kinds of crazy stuff so show
me a non functional movement you know I
don't know what that I don't know what
that means
versus a functional movement I mean I
get the basis of it but
anyway the point is is where we're made
to move and we're made - we're made to
move through these ranges of motion with
these given exercises and just trying to
associate them with what is going to
make those exercises improve to get
stronger is gonna be probably the most
functional and easiest way to get
through these workouts so if we look at
say three primary exercises we're
looking at the bench press the squat so
let's we I mean we could make it
specific and say it's kind of a low bar
wider squat maybe for power of thing and
then deadlift and you could you could
pick conventional or sumo whichever you
want to talk about what would be some
lesser-known assistance exercises that
you found valuable for each of those
when it comes to both the deadlift and
the squat and not that its lesser-known
necessarily because some coaches really
understand the value of it I love single
leg stuff whenever you have an
opportunity to do something standing or
whether you're whether and anytime you
have the opportunity to do something
with one leg or one arm I think you're
you're better off so but not not because
the main barbell movements are great we
do so many of them already that's kind
of the beauty of doing these single leg
or unilateral exercises so think about
lunges think about step ups anything
like that is going to be give you a
different stimulus and it's also gonna
kind of take you through a range of
motion that's going to kind of
dynamically stretch the opposite hip and
stretch the opposite leg and it's gonna
create a lot of motion a lot of times
when we're lifting we're not really
moving around a whole lot especially
when it comes to the bench or comes to
the squad or even comes to the deadlift
there's just not enough motion going on
with those movements so my favorites for
deadlifts aside from the unilateral
stuff my favorite stuff for dead lifting
is simply partial range of motion
deadlifts which it would be you can
deadlifts off of some blocks or
deadlifts out of a rack and that can
help build up the lower back help build
up the upper back and therefore help
with your overall dead lifting
performance one thing that people don't
sometimes
realize is that when you do a partial
range of motion deadlift because it
builds up your lower back you can build
up your speed off the floor so sometimes
I think people think oh I'll do a
deficit deadlift which would be you
increasing the range of motion of the
deadlift by standing on top to the block
or something yeah exactly but yeah by
standing on something or maybe instead
of using 45 pound plates maybe only use
your 35 pound plates or something
smaller than a 45 pound plate and
circumference so those are you know
there's a lot of options when it comes
to like how do I figure out how to get
faster off the floor but anybody I've
ever worked with they've gotten faster
off the floor from getting stronger and
from handling more weight rather than
handling less weight which sometimes the
deficit pull can actually make you
handle less weight so whenever you can
kind of find something that's gonna
allow you to handle more weight but
still I don't want to say safe because
none of this stuff is all that safe once
we once you start really getting after
it can be can be dangerous I don't want
to sell people on a bag of goods that's
not true but once you start to handle
some big weight so anytime you have an
opportunity to do something safely and
effectively you might as well go for it
and in the case of say benchpress what
are some movements as assistance
exercises or warm-ups that that you've
consistently usually that might not be
obvious to just a recreational lifter
benchpress I'll tell talking about
assistance movements first obviously I'm
the inventor of sling shot so I'm always
gonna back that thing up but the sling
shot is not valuable for the reasons
that people think it's valuable for a
lot of times people want to just handle
more weight with it they just want to
load up a ton of weight and it can be
used for that it can be used for that
very effectively but here in my gym what
we do is we use it for more reps and
more sets so once we're done with kind
of our main lift for the day I want to
also say we don't exclusively just use a
sling shot all the time we do a lot of
work without the sling shot on the sling
shot makes up 20 or 30% of our overall
bench pressing however if we're hurt
it'll make up about half of what we do
so we'll go through normal workout
anybody out there listening that's you
know likes to do certain styles of
training go ahead and do whatever that's
ty
is five to five or three sets of three
once you're done with that I throw a
slingshot on and do three extra sets
three to four extra sets add about 20
pounds per set or add weight as needed
each person's gonna be a little bit
different and just follow through it the
same exact reps that you did with your
raw work so you know this is a sample
workout if I did three sets of three
with 275 I would then put on 295 for
three with the slingshot on 315 with the
slingshot on for another set of three
and then I'd finished with 335 for
another set of three all three of those
sets are sets I'd normally would have
never been able to do without being able
to throw the slingshot on the slingshot
it's going to give you it's gonna allow
you to handle more weight it's gonna
allow you to do more reps more sets
handle more overall volume in your
training and the method that's referred
to when you talk about slingshot or
reverse band training is called the
future method you're getting your body
ready for heavier weights that's gonna
be able to handle in the future and for
people who are familiar and please
correct me if this description doesn't
do it justice but the slingshot in this
particular use case because you can you
can use different types of slingshots
for different purposes right on the legs
and otherwise in this case if people can
imagine you lifting up your arms out in
front of you like Frankenstein like
Frankenstein and then if you were to
tape take a thick but elastic fabric and
I'm not doing justice and wrap around
you get near Apia like a knee wrap
around your upper arms right and then
lower a bar to your chest though that
fabric that material would make contact
with your chest in the lowest portion
the weakest range of motion right and
help you to accommodate that larger
weight and I it goes without saying but
knowing the Internet I'm gonna say it
anyway you guys have very good spotters
here yes so you're not just walking into
your garage and slapping on more than
your max yeah you know one rep capacity
and then open for the best yeah if you
want if you want to see cautionary tales
on that you should just look up
benchpress accidents by male benchpress
fail on youtube to give yourself
nightmares
the what about back work is there any
particular type of back work that is
helpful are important to the bench press
and I personally am number one not
terribly good at the bench press it's
not part of my regular regimen right now
with focus on gymnastics but a lot of
people are very interested in it I saw
you doing for instance when we came in
band polls of some right so I'd love for
you to talk about maybe some warm-ups
that you use for it and secondly just as
a as a note for people who are wondering
when we came in you were just think in
the process of getting warmed up and I
said well when when you want to pick up
doing the podcast you're like well I'm
gonna start doing my workout and getting
into it probably thirty five minutes and
I said it's not like you're in the gym
for four or five hours okay but could
you talk about the the warm-up and back
work that's that's helpful just before
we move on to some of the back stuff I
just want to give you a couple exercises
without the sling shot cuz I hate to be
that guy that's over selling something
close grip bench press very simple go go
with a closer grip than what you're used
to don't go with such a close grip that
it crushes your elbows and it hurts
really bad whenever you're in pain
you're probably doing something wrong or
there's something from a long time ago
that's bothering you there's other
options so there's other ways of doing
it but simply just go closer than
whatever your normal grip is if you find
that you're very strong with the close
grip then try to go with a wider grip
and again don't go out so wide that
you're feeling all this pain and your
shoulders and stuff pain is a great
indicator of like something ain't right
it's kind of like it's kind of like if
you pulled the food out of your fridge
from a few days ago and you heated it up
and stuff and you went to eat it and
smells really bad and you decide just to
eat it anyway well you might there's you
might get sick right you might continue
to do more damage you might get hurt if
you have pain while you're doing some of
these some of these movements so if
something's not something feels weird
it's weird for a reason and you'll have
to try to find something different to do
another thing that can help the
benchpress tremendously and it's the
easiest thing to do is to do pause work
take weights pause them on your chest
count for you know three Mississippi's
or so you get a good three-second count
in there and then press when you press
the weight back up make sure you're not
sinking the weight back into your body
more
make sure you staying tight the entire
time you're trying to stay so connected
to the bar that you're kind of zeroing
the weight out but you're not zeroing
the weight out by resting it on your
body you're just creating so much
tension and so much tightness that
you're literally just kind of holding
the bar just just barely touching your
t-shirt that'll build up a tremendous
amount of strength and it will help a
ton with your form
I call it idiot proofing the bench press
because sometimes you get some people
that get excited they want to move
really fast and explosively show you how
strong they are
and they start going all haywire the
left arms going and right arm using
their ribcage as a trampoline yeah yeah
they're going just buck wild right it's
just cool it's great - it's great to be
motivated but you know try doing some
pause work you'd be surprised on how
much it can really help your bench press
moving into some back movements the
movement that you saw that I was doing
here it's very simple we just had some
bands attached to a machine and anything
stationary that's bolted down or
anything that's heavy in the gym height
that won't it won't come shooting back
at you when you when you put a band
around it would be a good a good thing
to use it's something you could do in
your garage very easily as well you can
do at home again making sure that
whatever it is you hook it to is very
secure all it's doing is just you know
pulling the bands towards me and you're
pulling them sort of towards eye level
yeah you know I there's no wrong a right
way to do it you just pull wherever you
want to pull - we have we have a very
scientific thing in here that we talk
about quite often somebody says hey Mark
you know how many represent you I always
tell them some for a few you know or the
old Muhammad Ali r.i.p
Muhammad Ali saying of you know how many
reps did you do when he did sit-ups and
he said I only count I only counted reps
once they started to hurt those are the
only reps they count no pain no gain
there's really no wrong or right way to
do this all you're trying to do is
you're trying to get the upper back kind
of warmed up and what I'll do is I'll
pull and I'll hold for five seconds try
to hold my I'll try to keep my my
positioning of my ribcage upward and
I'll pull really hard with pull my arms
back behind my body as far
I can which is not very good for Meeks
my range of motion isn't it's fairly
crappy but then from there I'll walk
away from the rack and what that does is
it put them put some more tension on the
band's and then from there I'll just
move my elbows up and I move my your
arms or bit my arms are bent right
you're simulating in in a way the
benchpress position yeah right right
yeah and it's like a standing row or
whatever you want to call it standing
bench or whatever and so yeah what that
does is it's kind of activating my lats
it's getting my back kind of ready to go
and I'll continue to kind of move my
arms around in different positions
sometimes I'll find something that feels
a little awkward it doesn't feel right
and so I'll hang out and I'll move
around in that position longer or I'll
say oh [ __ ] that's a little bit weird
maybe I should get on a foam roller and
maybe I should figure out what is that
back there what's going on in that spot
you know something I didn't I maybe
didn't notice and maybe I didn't notice
I slightly tweaked something at some
other point in my training the warm-up
is an evaluation of how you're doing for
the day and so that's that's I agnostic
cool right a hundred percent it's
actually since since I saw you at the
previous location and saw you doing sort
of face I can what would you call it
like its face pulls but you're using
cables and you're also using bands and I
started doing that and I still do that
yeah
even at the beginning of my gymnastics
routines and I have a stall bar you
don't need to get one of these
necessarily they're real pain in the ass
to install it's like a gigantic ladder
on the wall it's a real pain a non stall
bar and but I'll do the the work with
bands and whatnot like you said to
diagnose if there is an issue right
before I put a lot of load on it and I'm
like oh my left and infraspinatus is
really grumpy today therefore I'm gonna
lay down and like put a lacrosse ball
underneath it and then do internal
external rotation until it calms the
[ __ ] down so I don't below it apart when
I try to do something on the Rings yeah
and it just it's also possible it's just
not in the cards for that data to do
anything all that spectacular you start
to move around you're like man I don't
know what's going on and maybe something
happen at home that you're pretty upset
about maybe you're not feeling good and
yada yada and all of a sudden you kind
of got this downward spiral things that
are kind of against you for the day and
that maybe it's not in the car
for you to lift all that heavy for that
particular day the other thing I do is I
just turned back around the other way
with the bands so I'll just turn facing
away from the bands the setup you saw
that I had I have two bands I have one
band choked around the rack and then I
have another band going through the
other band so I so I have two basically
handles for the bands where I can press
and pull and do whatever so I'll turn
the opposite way and on bench press with
the bands
I'll let the bands go way up over my
head and I'll let them pull on my my
arms pull my arms back behind my body
I'll let the band sit into my hands
which will pull my wrist and I'll help
stretch my forearms I have extremely
tight forearms and elbows and just I
gots different stuff pulling on
different things and in a bunch of
different directions one of my favorite
warm-ups I don't do a ton of warm-ups
for squatting but for whatever reason I
need a lot of one I just basically come
in and start squatting a lot of times I
will sometimes use my hip circle to warm
up for a few minutes hip circles like
fire hydrant type stuff on the ground or
a hip circle is a product that I have
from how much bench ah there we go throw
it up over your knees and you just start
walking with it you can use a band as
well some people take a band make a
circle out of a band and I'll walk
forward in sideways and I've got monster
walks or whatever X well exactly yeah
just trying to just trying to walk
around move around get the hips ready
get everything fired up before you start
your workout you're kind of asking your
body a lot is the main thing to kind of
recognize that if you're working all day
and now you're just gonna come in the
gym and you think they're to perform
great without really warming up you got
another thing coming usually so you you
want to you want to do something that's
realistic for you to do the second you
get out of your car you can hop on an
Aerodyne bike or some sort of some sort
of stationary bike there's a lot of
different things you can do you get on a
treadmill you can even go for a walk
before you go to the gym or walk to the
gym or ride your bikes to the gym
there's a lot of different options you
can do but you want your body
temperature to be up my favorite thing
to do though in the gym is a which I can
show you in a little while is a bench
press where you just take the barbell
and you just move the barbell around in
a bunch of funky different positions so
let's say
you have one pinky pinky pinky on one of
the power rings of the bar you take your
other hand and you put it as close as
you can I guess right where the knurling
is about to end on the inside on the
inside right so you have one hand out
really wide basically in one hands ain't
a lot closer
take the weight down and let the weight
push your shoulder down in position you
can even actually have a little bit of
barbell weight on here if you're really
stuck together the way I am sometimes
and what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get the shoulder to drop back
down in position and to open up and
you're trying to get the barbell to
touch your rib cage so you're doing some
internal rotation with that doing a lot
of very intense internal rotation and
what you would end up looking like is
end up looking like you're doing like
some sort of weird funky chicken dance
paddling like wrote head with with a
barbell so one one side of the barbell
is down it's almost hitting the ground
the other side of the barbell is at full
locked out position to where it's almost
up over the rack he ends up looking at
Rosia very strange but we do that warm
up in here pretty much all the time and
we'll take some video of that guy's and
put it in the show notes at 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcasts so
that'll be in the show notes also we
will also just take the bar and hold it
in position and will like typewriter it
back and forth that's just made up that
term I was pretty good huh but basically
just kind of like you're moving it back
and forth sideways like yeah just moving
it back and forth sideways just anything
to get those shoulders open up but when
I show you especially how tight I am
after bench pressing you're gonna laugh
because the barbell is going to be
several inches from my chest or stomach
or wherever I bring the bar down to but
after I start to move like that the bar
will cleanly touch my body
well I'll laugh at your mobility and you
can laugh at my strength that's really
the only way this is gonna continue or
developing our relationships right so I
want to shift gears just a little bit
actually one question before I do and
this is a question from from Twitter
which is actually posted by Nassim
Nicholas Taleb NN Talib who wrote the
Black Swan and fooled by randomness two
great books really
yeah yeah so what is the max deadlift
for a non-competitive Flener I mean that
is just a non-competitive lifter like
himself adjusted by age group that would
be considered decent so let's just say
you have a 40 year old guy non-athlete
recreational lifter what would you
consider I'm just gonna make up some
numbers so 180 pounds right maybe 15
percent body fat you know get going
towards a molt multiple body weight
deadlift is a great place to start so
you know this case the guy we'd what 180
yeah let's just say well yeah like a 360
or a 405 deadlift would be really you
know getting like four plates on there
would be a would be an awesome goal I
think you know a lot of times people
think because I power lifts they
sometimes will tell me oh yeah I don't
lift like you man I'll say I don't know
what do you lift you know and then
they'll say oh you know my best bench is
like that's only like 225 and you know I
deadlift is like 350 and I'm I'm the
first person to be like well what did
you do when you started and they'll say
well when I first started like I think I
benched 95 pounds and then I'll be like
well what you're doing now is [ __ ]
awesome what are you talking about why
you beating yourself up so bad for you
know in the sport of power of thing the
commitment to gaining size and the
commitment to the nutrition and the
commitment to sleeping and the
commitment to even performance-enhancing
drugs there's just so many levels of
commitment that competitive power
lifters take that your average person
doesn't care to go there so the fact
that they can lift 200 300 400 it's
still really impressive really what
we're trying to do as power lifters and
sometimes we get very carried away with
it just as you can with any other sport
we just end up taking it to that next
level and we're trying to do the same
thing you're trying to do we're trying
to it's just about self-improvement
however our definition of success our
definition of self-improvement gets to
be really swayed after a while because
we're really trying to push the envelope
and if you guys want to see examples of
that you can watch the bigger stronger
faster with footages on the west side
lifters including yourself
of guys with like blood shooting out of
their noses at the bottom of competitive
squats
yeah and whatnot yeah some people like
who would desire to do that you know and
there's other people like [ __ ] yeah I
mean that's great I love that you know
so you had you had a period of time when
you were doing pro wrestling and that
was a real focus for you I want to talk
about a video that I saw oh we're just
gonna talk about I want to I want to get
into a couple of stories so there are a
bunch of things that popped up on social
media and I when I mentioned that you're
gonna be on the show and I asked people
what I should ask you about and and
we're not gonna go directly to this is
gonna be stepped two first I want to ask
you about the [ __ ] your elbow piece
we're gonna get to that but then there
were all these questions or requests to
ask you about hoop stories and I don't
know what the context is there maybe you
have some background that I don't but
can you can you explain for people the
background on the [ __ ] your elbow
shenanigans what happened there and how
does it tie into professional wrestling
yeah so I did professional wrestling for
about five years my oldest brother Mad
Dog Mike Bell he passed away several
years ago now but he was big into
wrestling and me and my brothers as kids
loved pro wrestling
I was asked one day randomly by a guy at
Gold's Gym and forever thought about pro
wrestling and I said I think about it
all the time I watch it all the time I
love it
and he's like well how would you like to
try out for some wrestling and I was
like okay it sounds cool to me give it a
shot you know long story short as I
ended up doing pro wrestling for about
five years I progressed pretty well I
ended up wrestling in the WWE kind of
training grounds which was in Louisville
Kentucky just kind of ran out of ran out
of juice there in terms of my desire to
continue to do it I had a kid at the
time and my son Jake who's now 12 so a
while back but you know at the time you
know I was pretty hungry to do it and
once I had my kid and stuff and I was
like well I don't really know what I'm
doing because now if I was assigned with
what you know if I did something with
wrestling I'd be traveling all the time
it just wouldn't create a great family
environment so anyway that ended but I
learned a lot from pro wrestling I
learned how to do wrestling promos you
need to put you on the spot and I'd say
hey you're wrestling tim ferriss july
31st you got 30 seconds smelly go ahead
you know and so then I would go and I
would say smelly is my nickname my two
older brothers gave me so that was the
name I used when I was wrestling as well
but they do all kinds of things like
that they'd swerve you and they throw
things at you you'd have to improvise
yeah it's improvised that you'd even say
like you know hey you're gonna do an ad
for this bar soap you know you got and
so I'd be like oh well you know I'm not
smelling anymore after using this bar
soap or something silly you decide to go
through it right because there's like 50
other wrestlers watching you too and so
yeah you know it felt like an idiot but
after a while you start to have fun with
it you become more comfortable with it
and you started to really learn I have
many haters on the Internet as I'm sure
you have acquired a few yourself oh yes
it's the tax you pay for being on the
mana and for some reason it's our
singular focus rather than the people
that love us tell us what a great job we
do and how inspiring we are we always
focus on the negative right that's the
way it goes so anyway this guy was you
know he said I can't believe you know
you tell people not to worry about their
central nervous system and that they're
using that as an excuse to not train and
this and that just at the time stuff
about the nervous system kept popping up
over and over again and I was just
getting tired of hearing people use
these excuses about how they needed like
auto regulate their training and they
need you need special programming and
all this [ __ ] and so I was like you know
I'm just gonna cut a wrestling promo on
this guy I'm just gonna give it to him
straight and so I went on to kind of say
you know what here's the truth we we're
all gonna die one day we're all gonna be
in a lot of pain we're all heading there
it's inevitable death is a part of life
and was thinking of that and knowing
that the time that you spend on this
earth you might as well live it as a
[ __ ] savage and train and do whatever
the [ __ ] you want and so when I said
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] your elbow I meant it
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] your elbow and so he
was complaining about his elbow as well
or yeah yeah once so once that um
because I think in the video that I
talked about the central nervous system
or something I said well maybe you're
using an excuse because your elbow hurts
or something well I say [ __ ] your elbow
just go in there and train don't worry
about you know
you know what do they say a violent
attack today is better than a
well-planned attack tomorrow that's kind
of the mindset it's like just go get the
[ __ ] work done I don't care about the
complaints I don't care about your
[ __ ] excuses it's kind of like you
know you want certain work to be done
you have certain jobs that you want to
be done from your camera crew that's
right here you don't want to hear them
saying that their lower back hurts or
whatever there's just job there's this
[ __ ] work to do right there's stuff
to get done you don't care obviously you
do care if they're if they don't feel
good right but at the same time there's
[ __ ] to get done and so that's just the
way I kind of view that and the old
wrestler and me kind of popped out for
that moment and attack that guy so so
you've done a couple of wrestling promos
right that have traveled pretty well
yeah result on the on the interwebs yeah
a more recent one was with well I don't
even know if he's a long-term friend
anymore but I don't know what happened
with us with Mike O'Hearn you know who
am I going to is yeah could you well
maybe you could tell people who do not
know who is yeah so Mike O'Hearn is a
has been on the cover of 500 magazines
or so according to himself of course I
don't know if there's any real data to
back that up
but Michael Hernon has been on the cover
of about 500 magazines he's a fitness
model he's been around for 25 plus years
or so he's always been in great shape
he's probably 6-2 or 63
he's probably 250 260 he's always
claimed to be natural and so he when
he's old meaning drug-free natural mean
drug meaning drug-free and before the
internet came around when he would say
drug-free and stuff everyone's just like
oh yeah know what no one really cared as
the internet progressed and as YouTube
became popular you saw a lot of these
drug tested lifters and a lot of drug
free natural bodybuilders become
insanely popular to the point where they
have 300 400 500 800,000 followers and
those people started saying you know
what some of these people are full of
[ __ ] sand their natural was who is this
guy over here and who Zak
over there and so that's kind of stuff
that's happened with Mike O'Hearn all
the way to the point where they is they
they gave him a new name his name is now
Mike Oh trend it's for trembling you're
a trend baloney oh there you go so
shrimp alone is in an antigenic anabolic
steroid that is particularly yeah
particularly popular among power I use
the code Tim Ferriss I'm kidding folks I
don't know but Rempel of ely stick
tablets that were used to inject and do
it yeah and then reconstitute or
basically right not that I would know
anything about that but continue so yeah
so anyway friend mike has been a friend
of mine for a long time we used to train
together we used to power them together
and so he made a video very short kind
of lame ish video on Instagram where he
called me out and he said I didn't
really mind it too much I mean it still
it doesn't really bug me much but the
one thing that I didn't like is he said
he's coming after my numbers and so I
was like you know what like just your
let your PRS yeah just to protect
powerlifting to protect the sport like
I'm not gonna tell him I'm gonna go up
and put it through a pose down with him
in my underwear and that's not that's
not what I'm good at that's not what I
know how does you he's won a lot of
competitions he'd whup my ass in that so
so I was like you know I'm just gonna do
I asked my brother and ask couple their
people like should I do like a wrestling
promo on him and you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah that would be funny and so I did a
whole promo you can kind of watch if you
watched on my youtube youtube.com
backslash super training o6 where I said
my coat ran your no longer my friend or
something like that isn't tight the
title of it you guys will get a kick out
of this all for fun and anyway Mike
retracted like whatever he put up I
haven't talked to him since then so I
don't really know I don't really know
where his mind is at with that but uh I
got him with a couple of good
hard-hitting things on there
what have you learned from some of the
lifters you've interacted with like Ed
Cohn for instance I mean the man the
myth yeah not really the myth the man
the legend I mean almost mythological
though mythological proportions yeah
what are there's a book by Marty
Gallagher that's right here how you do
it's a great book this is hard to find
it's not viable okay there it is okay so
this cone the man the myth the method
the lifetimes and training of the
greatest power lifter of all time
written by Marty gallagher this is a
[ __ ] great book it's unbelievable so
so it documents his uh all his different
contests and stuff like that it's it's
unbelievable so can you give people just
a little bit of background on Ed and why
people fear him so much and then Owen is
the greatest power of all time he's
regarded as the greatest power of all
time because he competed in the 220
pound weight class there's um a lot of
different weight classes in power and of
thing but from Ed cones standpoint
competing at 220 and 242 there's also
the 275 pound weight class there's a 308
weight class and then they're super
heavies which you know the super
heavyweights are guys at way over 308
someone weighing 350 and stuff like that
Edie was so strong that he was able to
topple Bill Kazmaier from back in the
day Kazmaier told a little bit over 2400
pounds and Ed was able to surpass him it
was kind of a lifelong journey for him I
think it was like 1991 or so was around
the time that he did it he also the the
style that he did it the way that he did
stuff was always super impressive
Bill Kazmaier people who don't know
number one they might recognize the name
from world Strongest Man competitions
just a beast Oh Bill Kazmaier was a
savage there's no question I mean the
way the guy was built was extremely
impressive he was he was very lean for
how heavy he was but you know when it
comes to American strongman competitors
he's he's a legend there's no doubt
about it even just in a history of
strongman period in American or
otherwise he's a legend so I interrupted
you though you're saying his you're
talking about Cohn and his is meth
his technique it's not just what Edie
Kohn did is how he did it a lot of times
as well he's not a guy that cut corners
he's a guy that kind of used old-school
methods he uses hard work he's a tough
bastard his tough guy and he's not gonna
let anything hinder they don't let
anything get in the way of him being the
best and so on his quest to topple this
all-time world record you know he would
hit these huge squats he'd hit a big
benchpress and then a lot of times it
would come down to the deadlift now
anybody who knows Edie Cohn he's one of
the greatest deadlift there's of all
time he did a nine hundred one-pound
sumo deadlift at one point at 220 pounds
a record that still stands to this day
mine mind-boggling he just had a belt on
for that lifts Edie Edie struggled a
little bit in the benchpress so so for
him to try to beat bill Kath Bill
Kazmaier by the way had the world record
in the bench press for a long time he
benched 661 pounds 300 kilos which is
just just another mind-boggling feat
what gear or lack thereof at the time
was I don't think just as my workbench
sure I think just like a singlet and a
bell
I think the 661 benchpress that Bill
Kazmaier did I could be wrong but I
think it was just a t-shirt
he built casma are also squatted like in
the mid 8
ramped up singlet of some sort didn't do
a whole lot for you some cheap knee
wraps and they would just go at it you
know and then bill also was able to pull
over 800 pounds so if Cohen had to make
up a lot of ground in the squat and the
deadlift because he couldn't bench as
much as Bill Kazmaier did but this one
particular meat that he did down in
Texas it came down to the deadlift and
Ed cone injured himself in training he
couldn't he couldn't bowl sumo so he
gets down to his last deadlift and he's
got to pull 887 pounds conventional so
sumo is wider stance hands inside the
legs conventional is kind of the
opposite likes closer together arms on
the outside correct
and so they're COEs dead cone he goes up
to the bar and he 887 pounds and just
like the true professional that he was
rips weight up off the ground locks it
out and it's kind of
only time you'll ever see him celebrate
you can find that video on YouTube it's
really neat to kind of watch because he
doesn't really celebrate he's usually
very stoic whenever he does it live so
he could see him get really fired up and
just a passion the guy has the one tot
the time that he did come out here and
the time that we spent with him here at
super training we shot some videos with
him we podcast with him and when he when
he left that day I told the rest of the
guys in the gym I'm like well that's it
like there's never that's it that's
that's to go that's the greatest of all
time they'll never be another egg cone
walking through the door so I was like
it's all just downhill from here or any
other lifter that way yeah and
everybody's laughing but but everybody
now understands why I said it because
he's a great person off the platform
he's a great he's a great person either
way you know so he's he's somebody that
I look up to in lifting and in life he's
super awesome guy to be around he's
always very happy he's always very
energetic
he loves sharing in for me he's gonna be
the first guy he's gonna be the first
guy to help you he's also gonna be the
first guy to brag that he helped you
which i think is funny he brags to me
all the time still this day about how he
helped this guy with that he helped that
guy with that and he's so excited about
it and it's just great to see but
something I learnt the main thing I
learned from him I guess two things when
it comes to lifting what I learned from
him is that he likes to just do one set
because he built up so he acquired so
much strength that he really only needed
the stimulus from like one main set one
main work set one main working set but
he would have warm ups of course of
course and warm ups I don't even know
what you would even call him because
it's seven hundred pounds then it's
seven hundred thirty pounds and seven
hundred sixty pounds and it's eight
hundred pounds and it just goes on
forever and ever so but but yeah they're
warmups they're very easy for him to do
you know there's seventy percent for him
eighty percent one thing that struck me
reading this book way back in the day
I've had it for ages is that his
training regimen is actually very
similar to the training regimen of
Dorian Yates
when we Yates when it was in his prime I
mean that the programming was very
similar
yeah there's kind of one and done you
know they get that main lift in there
the other thing I learned from
which is this is really hard to do I
would advise anybody to try to practice
this I challenge anybody to be able to
actually be able to follow through with
this because it's really hard to do but
this is a advice for med Cohn the
greatest power through all time he said
be nice to those who are nice to you and
that's it don't do anything else
and I always talk I always took that
it's like a challenge that's really hard
to do in life you get somebody being
mean or nasty to you the only thing you
could think of is like how do i
retaliate how do i how do I get this
person's attention so I get back to him
how do I get them to stop how do I you
know cut them off or I want to punch him
in the face whatever it might be and you
know that advice from him to me was was
was critical and it came at a really
good time I was having some issues with
a old member of the gym and stuff like
that and so it just kind of it kind of
relieved me of that tension that was
like you know what he's absolutely right
why don't I just you know why don't just
concentrate on what I'm doing
concentrate on the positive great things
I have going on just be nice with people
who are nice to you and then ignore the
rest ignore the rest are there any other
lifters for instance you've interviewed
some some just phenomenal athletes and
of course you have a ton of them here at
the gym but a few names that come to
mind because they're just like you put
it mind-boggling dmitriy klokov
constantine Konstantinov so you having
the name right yeah that guy good lord I
mean there's a video you guys can see
what what's the WA was at 9:45 985 with
just uh just a belt and no it was no
belt yeah no belt no no I have you have
you taken anything away from these guys
and Dmitry Clark office just a absolute
mutant of Olympic lifting have you taken
anything from those guys you've tested
or incorporated in your own training or
otherwise um you know sometimes when you
look at some of these guys you you do
have to recognize that there's just
different there's different species
among us you know there's some people
that are just different there's uh you
know there's a guy in high school who's
64 who's really lean who gets all the
chicks right I mean there's there's some
people that use this sometimes can't
keep up with for lack of a better term
you you don't know how to
compete with them and some of these guys
are like that like you're truly and
honestly just not ever going to be able
to compete with them at some of the
stuff they do we have a bit of lifter
here for a long time lifted us he was a
PhD in mathematics and he said I think
it was like second or third grade they
put some equations in front of them for
multiplication and division and they're
like we're gonna be going over this the
next month and you know we're gonna
review this and you guys will know this
like the back your hand he was like I
already know all the answers you know
there's there's people that are just
like that there's people that walk in
here I just told you a story today about
encima one of the lifters that we have
in here
he did a 715 pound deadlift I've been
working my whole life double double
overhand grip double overhand grip with
no belt
it was a hook grip you know double
overhand would be almost impossible with
that kind of weight I don't know if
there's anybody can do that
so grip just for people listening you
don't know this is with the four fingers
of your hand on top of the thumb correct
could not hurt any worse yeah I can't
anyway I mean nothing I'm trying to be
part of the conversation if you like one
of the boys obviously I can't even I can
freaking hold the water bottle for you
guys but so it has never been
comfortable trying I hope you know it
hurts like you know so I guess my point
is is that sometimes some of these guys
are on such another level it's hard to
really learn much from them at all I
guess like dmitriy klokov
this is like gonna sound ridiculous is
saying it but like one thing that he
really preaches to other other Olympic
lifters is to get stronger as funny as
that may sound
I think that what is referring to is
like hey you know what stop worrying
about like you know becoming more mobile
and stop worrying so much about your
technique in your form and he's like
it's not all these different things it's
just that you're a [ __ ] you're not
strong enough so work on being stronger
a lot of things can be really solved
through dead lifting and squatting and
so his point was hey you know what let's
just get more weight on your back like
this okay let's get have that be the
focus rather than you spending 10 hours
a day on your technique in the snatch or
something like that well you have a you
have a big mural and the gym there's a
strength is never a weakness okay and
you know one of the guests I've had on
the podcast Pavel suelen if you
popularize a kettlebell in the
university but also say strength first
like that is sort of the foundational
skill and then you can build everything
else on top of it it's true I would go
so far as to say with say Konstantin who
is not from Latvia alright he does need
doesn't get really any from Russia but
he lives in Latvia and he's like let's
get something clear like yeah yeah yeah
he pretty fired up yeah yeah it was
interesting and interviewing him his the
text that came back was like so like
harsh that when we started to edit it on
our end I was like oh no we need to
leave some of that in there I like how
he's like he's kind of like he's kind of
like really once and he was also kind of
mean to towards Americans like Americans
are weak and Russians are strong and
tough and that's like we're leaving that
in there like that sounds that sounds
great I love this guy it was a good
interview I mean I read the whole thing
and I actually underlined quite a lot
but what I what I was gonna say is that
in some cases it's it seems to me
dangerous to emulate some of the habits
of people who are in the top point zero
zero one percent correct because they've
already built such a a foundation of
strength training that they can then
break the rules right so he actually he
initiates a lot of his record-breaking
deadlifts with a rounded back right but
if you take someone who's just doing
saying to X body weight and when I get
to three times body weight they're like
oh now I should lift with around in rack
it's like well let's not put the cart
before the horse yeah a great a great
analogy for that would be you know
you've done some MMA type stuff you've
done some martial arts and stuff like
that
imagine just learning a few weeks of
martial arts and being like ok I want to
I want to start doing some stuff like
bones Jones and and where you try that
is in the UFC against another you know
against a professional fighter when
you've had no experience with that so
sometimes you got to just leave some of
the things up to the pros and recognize
that they're gonna look different when
they do things
Constantine Konstantinov it appears that
he lifts with a rounded back but he's
his back rounded or are his erector so
dense that when he goes to bend down his
spine just kind of looks that way it's
hard to really tell I mean the guys so
damn jacked it's hard to really
reference much of anything the thing to
learn from him though is the
blow cygnus and the intent he's he's not
out there to like to win a balloon or a
lollipop no he's he's trying to like
break stuff he's trying to be very
violent with the weights he's trying to
rip the weight off the ground as fast
and as explosively as he possibly can so
that's something you could that's a good
take-home message for people then also
realize he built up his deadlift by
utilizing by doing a lot of repetitions
I remember in the article he said it
used to do set to 10 and 15 routinely
you'll see that then often in the
deadlift it reminds me also although you
know Pavel and you need Dan John a lot
of you guys who would would if they're
looking at what they were called easy
strength they're probably doing fewer
repetitions per set but you know Pavel
has said to if you want to press a lot
you have to press a lot yeah yeah and
work on that that's skill and the
technique of a speaking out in those
positions for the positions that you're
bad and hang out in those positions for
a long time as you've gotten older what
have you added to your regimen if
anything to try to minimize the
likelihood of injury or spinal issues I
know one fan of mine had mentioned and I
don't know if this is accurate but the
ronnie Coleman's had a number of back
surgeries man were saw to see you know
Edie cone has had hit you know double
hip replacements Yeah right how do you
think about addressing that as you get
older because you're not just a power
lifter now right I mean you're also an
entrepreneur and you also you have a lot
of other projects and responsibilities
how do you think about that I don't you
know I can't be I can't be that worried
about tomorrow if I'm gonna do the
things that I that I really truly want
to do now now it would be irresponsible
not a thing about it at all so there are
some things that I added but when I say
them you'll laugh because it just sounds
silly to even say out loud but adding in
more food it's been a big part of it you
didn't want her eating more food yeah
more fuel you know you're gonna need
more fuel for the task see that you that
you need to be able to complete and and
that's not to say like that doesn't go
along with getting older probably less
food goes more along with getting older
than anything else but in order for me
to be competitive in order for me to
stay strong I mean
need to add food into what I'm doing so
food is gonna be a big part of it and
the sleep regimen is gonna be a big part
of it as ridiculous that sounds
Jesse Burdick and I laugh all the time
we wanted to start a website called rest
wad
how about snoozing all about sleeping so
I like hanging out with Jesse because he
has as large a head as I do oh my hell
of a cranium that's incredible how would
you suggest these also pockets like on
the side oh yeah it's great it's kind of
like a pit bull when you see people like
chewing oh my god what are those muscles
press so but Jesse is also I mean he can
pull a lot of weight yeah this is a real
athlete how much can be now I my first
real like hands-on interaction with
Jesse was getting a RT from Jesse oh no
I'm gonna come back to that in a second
but like what did what is Jesse pull do
you have an idiot his best deadlift in
competition I think is 821 821 it was a
strong unit very strong the candid young
man and I met him because I was having
lower back and hip related pain so
Active Release Technique for those
people are not familiar I'll try to give
a very oversimplified definition and
then just a short story on Jesse Dean oh
my god so the idea the basic idea and
this is going to be super oversimplified
is that if you have tissues let's just
say that our have developed scar tissue
and adhesions and there adjacent tissues
that you can have someone effectively
stick their fingers deep in between them
and then have you go through different
like gliding motions to tear it apart
I mean this is yeah roughly what it's
like now if you don't know where your
soaz is imagine basically a millimeter
next to your you junk your genitals
either either gender and it travels up
kind of through the hip and attaches to
the lower back and so people who sit
down a lot be very tight in the episodes
and hip flexors and then they stand up
and it pulls in the lower back ouch ouch
and so I decided to go see Jesse Bernick
at one point and he late you got me lay
down on a table with kind of my legs
dangling off and he said okay safe word
is brisket that's how he started which
is Jesse way to buy to 80 or so to 80
basically imagine making like a ridge
hand
like you're gonna sort of Austin Powers
judo chop someone and he it felt like he
sticked his he stuck his hand kind of up
to like the second knuckle into my groin
and then move my leg around like a
marionette it was I was a memorable day
I felt like I was I don't know like
welcome to Rikers out yes I've had
something similar done before and for
some reason even though their hand is on
your stomach it feels like someone's
fist is going up your ass it's like
weird feeling like what just happened
yeah tickling your spine from the front
I mean it's it's a very anger like I
don't know what's happening this usually
you have to go to a funky club in the
middle of nowhere at 3:00 in the morning
with with where right blue lights to get
that eye service but if just I guess Lee
Burdick flowers I mean he'll be willing
to do it all the time for you the rest
wad so what what what else do you have
the other element the other element of
the you know the staying healthy you
know as you get older is is just to make
sure that there's no stone unturned in
your training and make sure you're not
doing that stupid stuff at the end of
your workout that's gonna compromise you
know at the end of your workout you
always have you got the angel and the
devil on your shoulder and the angel is
always telling you hey you should go
home you should probably just rest you
should you know take take today as a win
buddy and just relax and you have to
devil telling you no you should do
another set you know you need to be more
jacked and so when you have that that
that sensation and want to do more stuff
you probably shouldn't especially if
you're already cooled down there's
there's other days to Train there's
other days to get the job done and it's
it's a long long process to get stronger
it's a long process to beef it's a long
process to stay in shape so view it as
that make sure you're getting in make
sure you're hydrated make sure you're
sleeping well and even if net if need be
then take a nap all these things are
gonna be crucial in your in your journey
towards succeeding at whatever it is
that your goals are and the the simple
stuff it's so funny how often and I've
found myself succumbing to this often
it's like you're not getting proper
sleep and yet you're gonna obsess unlike
the minut details of some tiny variation
of some exercises like no you
dumbass you just need to actually get
your sleep or take it 20-minute nap or
whatever it might be and the what you
just said echos true across a couple of
different fields because for instance in
surfing you know that that like just one
more wave it's like always when people
get so people like Laird Hamilton said
I'm never allowed to say that and then
you have people like Tim O'Neil is I
think a six-time national champion in
rally car racing and it's like at the
end of the day 4:30 like the witching
hour that's when everybody [ __ ] up and
drives a new tree or has some type of
accidents like mine's not connected to
anything anymore that's what you call it
and you know coach summer the former
national team gymnastics coach from
men's gymnastics has put it to me
because I'm also inclined to push it too
hard and particularly with connective
tissue
I get muscularly stronger quite quickly
but then my connective tissue lags and I
get injured and he said look if you if
you you can always push harder the next
training cycle or in the next workout
but if you overdo it today you might be
out for two or three weeks yeah and
everyone's always trying to have all
these crazy recovery methods and foam
rolling and doing all these other things
and all those things are great and they
can't they can really help a lot but if
you just don't Train like an idiot then
you don't need it as much
yeah these less of it
let's hit just a couple of rapid-fire
question here and then we can get back
into the gym and we can demo some of
these exercises the first one is one of
my most common questions that is when
you hear the word successful who's the
first person who comes to mind for you
then why my pops pops my dad yeah all
five foot four of them uh you know I got
a bo Jackson rookie card sitting right
here on this desk that we're at right
now and you know when I was a kid I
probably would have viewed that as like
success but you know what I've learned
over the years is that the success that
we embrace as Americans and success that
we that people are judged by can
actually be quite maddening to even ever
reach
and it's not always all that obtainable
you want to think about success and you
want to think about what it means to be
successful I don't know if people really
truly think about what the what the term
means to them that's the most important
thing like what does it actually mean to
you if you think being successful is
being in movies then look at any issue
of People magazine and see how many
divorces and see how many problems a lot
of these people have had that we would
normally put up on a pedestal and say
they're successful they have all the
same problems a lot of regular people
have but they're amplified and their
their lives spin out of control very
often through alcohol and other all
other kinds of problems as kind of
pointed out in prescription thugs those
types of things become very real to the
rich and famous and so success to me is
defined by the simple act of being good
for a long period of time and doing the
right thing over and over and over again
you know people want a fast way to
success people want a fast way to
getting better or self-improvement and
people often talk times talk about like
you know a steroid or this and that's
gonna get me here faster well the
ultimate pill that you could take is
again the act of doing the right thing
as often as you possibly can it's hard
because we have a lot of self-doubt in
our body we have we talk ourselves out
of stuff every day
we have naysayers we have people that
tell us that we can't so sometimes that
sneaks in and they're like oh yeah you
know what they're probably right I'm
probably right I probably can't do that
I should probably shouldn't be doing
that and so to me success is the ability
to continually get a lot of stuff done
whatever it is your goals may be to
continually make the right decision day
in and day out and see act of being good
for a very very long period of time
because being successful in being great
is not something that can happen just in
one particular day or one particular
month I've talked before about Michael
Jordan and talked before about Muhammad
Ali these are not people that were good
just a given day they were good for a
long period of time they did the right
thing for a long period of time and that
prepared them to be great when the time
was right and they stood the test of
time to me that's the ultimate form of
success is to be able to stand the test
of time I remember as a kid and as I
started getting more and more into girls
and stuff like that watching my dad and
seeing him as an example I remember a
couple times I'm like there's no way
that my dad is not gonna look at this
girl it's impossible there's no way this
girl has two little clothes on from not
turn his head and not look at this girl
when she walks by I don't care how in
love with mommy is just no way there's
no way it's not possible my dad would
never look and to me that's the
definition of greatness somebody who's
that disciplined and somebody can make
that sort of commitment I would just add
also that one thing I've admired about
what I've seen of your path and we
haven't hung out as much as as as I
would like but we we have interacted a
fair amount and you I think one enviable
aspect of what I've seen you do is that
and an admirable is that you don't take
yourself too seriously
and I think that like life life can be
really short it can be cut short ya can
also be really really or feel really
really long yeah so I think that the act
of not taking yourself too seriously is
allowed you to accomplish a lot of
really serious things and then that's an
awesome there's no question about it
Abbi you know having fun how can having
fun not be part of your success having
and I've at the same time you know if
you're not kicking ass not getting ahead
it's harder to have fun you know you
know make no mistake about it like like
I'm a driven person I want to kick as
much as the next person but at the same
time I don't I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
sacrifice my training or I'm not gonna
sacrifice such a serious person that I
think everything's gonna be diminished
or or interfered with if I have a couple
laughs before I go do a lift
now obviously before I load up the bar
with 600 pounds I'm not going to be like
the I'm not gonna be like the source of
entertainment for everybody for those
you know 15 20 30 seconds before I go
and do my lift soon as it's done though
you right back to your normal self
having a good time I just have learned
you know over a period of time that it's
not a it's not a great thing to to be so
self indulged in what you're doing it
can really as I mentioned earlier it can
be maddening when you're trying to chase
after certain numbers and certain things
it can it can really make or break you
and so I'd rather do it if I can't have
fun and chase at the same time I'd
rather fall a little bit short and have
fun along the way what $100 or less
purchase has most positively impacted
your life recently
oh man positively I was gonna say that
initially I'm gonna say a pair of
Groucho Marx glasses that I bought in
Japan a lot of legs out of those crotch
or marks buzzes yeah they were they were
about she liked him I can't remember how
she costs but they were like in the US
dollars they were like two bucks
but for some reason everybody wanted to
take a picture of me with something that
all the instantly made me famous somehow
I don't know how it happened but there's
like hundreds of p in your head yeah
there yeah human being wearing glasses
oh my god yeah we're the most Japanese
comic book thing and I was also wearing
a purple jacket Ribera Steakhouse purple
jacket satin nonetheless to make matters
even better but let's see $100 purchases
that is done what exactly just
positively impacted your life it could
be any purchase really I'm just looking
for something that's not like well my
new Escalade because yeah people are
just gonna run out and buy it you know
what the wife he does so many other
purchases around the house that okay I
can rephrase it yeah what is a piece of
gear that that you're extremely happy
with that people might not be familiar
with you shouldn't be one the triad is
that what it's called yeah yeah this was
pretty cool
yeah I saw another weird device which
looked like some modified type of
pulldown grip for lat pull-downs as
which I could remember the name of that
thing yeah is that thing
pretty we will take video of that so it
seems pretty badass in terms of the
lifting equipment in the gym and I
really like we have you know we have
well the everything in there so
expensive so it's you know there's
nothing ok yeah yeah there's what's
called the duffel Oh bar which is by a
friend of mine Chris Duffin basically
it's a kind of a spin on the Buffalo bar
which is a bar that is specifically bent
a certain way so it's less stress on
your elbows and shoulders when you go to
squat I like that piece a lot and then
we have something in the gym and I'll
introduce you to that you'll really like
it's also by Chris stuff and it's called
the Geisha and this thing is I believe
that's how you say it it's a hundred and
it's a hundred and twenty pounds of
cement that is in the shape of a foam
roller and you just roll it on your back
and roll it on your legs ah terrible and
magnificent insane I have seen a number
of products from him so he also makes
there's like the widow or the the
Widowmaker or whatever all these days
yeah they're like weighted cylinders
yeah yeah Donnie Thompson makes some of
the stuff as well they I think they make
some stuff in conjunction and one of the
things he makes is called the ex-wife
and it's like a hundred fifty times like
that pretty a try it's pretty cool as
well which is basically thick bar or you
could use it for thick bar training but
it has three different ya grips on each
let's just call it well try it 20 pounds
40 pounds 60 pounds my friend my friend
who makes those is a huge fan of yours
so he's if he listens to this he's gonna
he's hearts just gonna well I was gonna
ask you if I could buy a few of them
actually saw the name of the company's
havoc if we can plug it he'll haven't ya
fantastic yes check it out folks if you
could have one billboard anywhere with
anything on it that is not an
advertisement if you could just put like
a phrase or anything on it what would
you what would you put up there I like
the quote you know that quote that some
of the quotes we have in the gym but one
of my favorite quotes of all time is
either you're in or you're in the way
and a little little backstory on that I
won't go too long into it but
a friend of mine I was uh I was single
at the time and I was dating a few girls
and was trying to find the right one I
was trying to find mrs. Bell and you
know I wanted a few dates with my now
wife Andy and my friend at the time a
little Italian guy very fiery very
excited Danny DeVito like sort of guy
but then also super jacked and super
ripped and built and talked 100
miles-an-hour chain-smoked like a
[ __ ] but looked like a pro
bodybuilder the same time it was weird
combination of [ __ ] going on his uh his
name was his name was his nickname was
Vinny goo BOTS he was so abrasive and
when he was talking to you he always
looked like he was like getting in a
fight with you but he's just telling you
a story but he's always moving his hands
around so much and he was so energetic
and loud and stuff he used to stay at
her house a lot my brother just let him
stay at the house for a while he was
kind of down and out for a period of
time and my wife ended up seeing him out
somewhere and then they spent like a few
hours together they hung out at the
beach together and stuff like that while
he's smoking and cursing up a storm at
the beach my wife thought he and I were
really good friends it was just more of
an acquaintance than anything else that
my wife was trying to just spend time
with him and and to get on my good side
basically and so Vinny comes home and he
tells me he's like hey I saw Andy you
know and we were hanging out she's super
sweet she's super nice girl why he's
going on and on and he's like you know
he's like you're a [ __ ] idiot I don't
know why you know you're with this girl
you with that girl you complain and he's
like he goes I got a saying either
you're in or you're in the [ __ ] way
he's like an Andy she's in
and so that speech right there led to
Andy and I being married for 15 plus
years now and having two children either
you're in or you're in the way I love it
well mark I tell you what we could we
could talk and talk and talk and we'll
do around to sometime but I want to let
you get back to training we're going to
film some stuff that people can see in
the show notes so some grab some video
and probably also finds some of your
your tie rates your professional
wrestling challenge videos to put in the
show notes but I where can people find
you what would
you'd like them to check out how can
they reach you or learn more about you
on the interwebs etc yeah so Instagram
it's at mark smelly Bell on Instagram
and Twitter I'm have a website called
how much you bench net which has all my
products which is they're all supportive
gear to help you lift more weight to
help you lift more weight more safely
and then also you're gonna want to check
out my youtube channel which has tons
and tons of great information on
training its youtube.com backslash super
training o6 all right well there we have
at any parting comments suggestions
things you'd like listeners of the
podcast to consider just multiply your
muscle and multiply a hustle all right
mark thanks so much everybody thank you
appreciate it and everybody listening as
always you can find links to everything
we discussed and more resources etc in
the show notes for this episode and
every other episode at 4 hour work week
comm forward slash podcast and as always
until next time thanks for them
available for more of these if you need
me I can take over a little bit when
you're not around
anything you need money substitutes mark
bell thank you guys
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom I have used LegalZoom myself
for many of my businesses and many of
the icons on this podcast have actually
used LegalZoom for instance Matt
Mullenweg of WordPress Fame CEO of
automatic which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on LegalZoom LegalZoom is a
reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted help
with their businesses whether that's
setting up will doing a proper trademark
search forming an LLC setting up a
non-profit or finding simple cease and
desist letter templates man do I use a
lot of those LegalZoom is not a law firm
but they do have a network of
independent attorneys available in most
states they can give you advice and the
best way to get started provide contract
reviews and otherwise help you run your
business and important there are no
surprises LegalZoom provides complete
transparency that means upfront pricing
customer reviews and a satisfaction
guarantee check out legalzoom.com
today to see how they can make life
better and easier for you and your
business if you're pretending to be a
lawyer on the internet then you are
asking for trouble put together the
safety nets get your t's crossed and
your eyes dotted enter promo code tim t
IM at legalzoom.com to save 15% that's t
IM for 15% off check it out
legalzoom.com this episode is brought to
you by 99designs I've used 99designs for
years for all sorts of graphic design
needs whether you need a logo website
cover anything else 99designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone but to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers from the 4-hour body
I want the contest drop that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late night quick
turnaround while people in other time
zones other countries can also help you
solve that problem
since then I've worked with 99designs on
a separate path or a different option
and that is the one-to-one project
service so in a number of cases not give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book the Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators it blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free and $99
upgrade on your first design again
that's 99 designs com4 slash Tim
[Applause]